>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Nicholas Brown: Good
afternoon and welcome
to the Library of Congress.
My name is Nicholas Brown,
and I work with the Office
of Special events and
Public Programs.
It is my great pleasure
to welcome you here today
to the historic Coolidge Auditorium.
Today we are celebrating Hispanic
Heritage Month at the Library
of Congress, and we're very pleased
to be joining hands with Discovery
and Espanol and Verizon
[inaudible] for today's events.
These events are presented
in conjunction
with the library's semiannual
main reading room open house
which takes place several
times throughout the year.
You can visit our website for more
information about that, loc.gov.
Today's events have included
[inaudible] story time
and children's activities,
tours of the Explorer,
the Early America's Exhibit and
also Treasures Displays relating
to [inaudible] and National
Hispanic Heritage Month.
The library's Hispanic
collections are curated
by the Hispanic division whose
chief is Georgette Dorian
[assumed spelling].
This afternoon's film screening and
interview will kick off shortly.
We're going to present Discovery
in Espanol's Documentary.
Benito Juarez [inaudible] is a 45
minute television docudrama special
directed by Carlos [inaudible].
The film is presented in Spanish.
Immediately following the film, we
will have an interview on the legacy
of Benito Juarez and
covering the film as well.
The panel will be Michela
Giorelli who is the Vice President
of Production and Development
at Discovery Communications,
Barbara Tenenbaum, a retired
Hispanic specialist at the Library
of Congress' Hispanic Division
and the moderator will
be Talia Guzman Gonzalez
who is a reference librarian and
[inaudible] Brazilian specialist
in the library's Hispanic division.
The interview will be
presented in English.
Throughout the event and as you
go home and ponder the film,
we invite you to join us on social
media with the hashtag lchispanic.
I'd also like to draw
your attention to some
of the upcoming Hispanic
Heritage Month events
which are listed in your program.
On Wednesday, October 11 at 3
o'clock p.m., we have a lecture
with [inaudible] who
is an art historian
on Francisco [inaudible]
in the United States.
On Thursday, October
12, we have a lecture
with Chrissy Arse [assumed spelling]
from the University of Miami
on Mexico's [inaudible]
cultural legacy
of the [inaudible] Mexican women.
Finally on Friday evening at 7 p.m.
in the Pickford Theater we
will be screening Selena.
All of these events are
free and open to the public.
Tickets are available.
Visit us at loc.gov
for more information.
I'd also like to draw your attention
to a new Hispanic themed
podcast series
that the library's Hispanic
division has recently launched
in the last week in conjunction with
National Hispanic Heritage Month.
It is fabulous, and it's a great
insight into recording archives
of Hispanic literature
and culture as well
as the physical archives
here at the library.
Without further adieu, thank you for
being here and thanks to Discovery
and [inaudible] of course in
particular for working with his
and to Verizon [inaudible]
for supporting this program,
and we look forward to seeing
you at the end of the event.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez: So I
have a couple questions prepared
for Barbara Tenenbaum, and
Michela, and please feel free to --
at any point if you want to ask
a question or would like them
to develop any further
to just jump in.
There might be a microphone
somewhere around here.
If not, just raise your hand,
and I think we're close
enough that we can hear you.
Thank you so much for allowing
us to show this documentary here.
I would -- the movie
begins in [inaudible].
So we're already -- the
conflict's already started.
And later on one of
the speakers mentions
that Benito Juarez was
democratically elected president.
Can you, Barbara and Michela also
as well tell us a little bit more
about Benito Juarez and
his rise to presidency?
How did he get there?
I know it's a big question,
but [crosstalk] background
and context for her.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum:
It's an amazing story,
and one that Mexicans
cherish very much.
Benito Juarez was from the state
of [inaudible] in the south,
which is an indigenous state.
He was Zapotec Indian both sides,
although interestingly enough
the Mexicans don't consider him
to be an Indian because
culturally he was not.
At the age of three,
he was orphaned.
He lost both his parents.
And he basically walked from
his little village to the city
of Oaxaca, and apprenticed
himself to a lawyer,
and he ultimately became a lawyer.
The mythology says that he
married the lawyer's daughter,
but that's under dispute
at the moment,
but he certainly married Margarita,
and he went on from there.
He became governor of
the state of Oaxaca,
and he was an avowed opponent
of Antonio Lopez de Santa Anna
who you probably have heard of.
And Santa Anna exiled him.
And he was in the United
States in New Orleans
where he was a reader
in a tobacco factory.
Tobacco factories in
those days had --
while people were making the cigars,
they would have a reader read
to them from books or the
newspaper or whatever,
and he performed that function.
As soon as the revolution of
Ayutla in 1854 was declared,
Juarez and a lot of other
Mexican exiles left the U.S.
and went back to Mexico.
Santana resigned from the presidency
the following year in 1855
and Juarez became the Minister
of Justice in the cabinet
and he is responsible for
a law called the Le Juarez
in which the church and the army
lose their special privileges,
which was one of the
first blows struck
against the church in that period.
Then very -- the head of the
government, Juan Alvarez,
resigned in favor of
Ignacio Comonfort
so everybody changed a
little bit their positions
and ultimately Juarez became
the head of [inaudible]
and then seated to the presidency.
But Mexico goes through a
horrible period from 1858
when the government was taken
over by conservatives until 1867,
which you saw in the film when
they throw out the French.
And from that point on except
for a very small interlude
during the revolution,
the conservatives never ever
take power again in Mexico
or at least not by [inaudible].
You can make your own
judgments about that.
Benito Juarez died in
1872, and when you go to --
I'm not going to say if,
when you go to Mexico City,
you will see [inaudible] there is
what is called the [speaking foreign
language], which is
dedicated to Benito Juarez.
This was put together
by his successor,
Porfirio Diaz who was
also from Oaxaca.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez: Would you
like to add anything
to that, Michela?
>> Michela Giorelli: Yes, I
mean, what I want to add is
that [inaudible] Espanol, we
are always looking for subjects
that are relevant to
our Hispanic audience
and 2017 marks the
150 year anniversary
of the restoration of the republic.
And we always had wanted to do
something about Benito Juarez
because he's like a national
hero, a national icon in Mexico.
He has become a single Mexican
nationalist and also a symbol
of resistance to foreign
intervention, and he is also --
you were mentioning he's
considered one of the propellers
for the [inaudible] reform changes
that took place in the 19th century.
So it's still very
relevant in present days,
and he's the only president
that has a public holiday.
His birthday is a public
holiday in Mexico, March 21.
And but also what I think -- I
think Mexico love a lot about him is
that he fought for equalitarian
rights, obviously had to fight
against a lot of prejudice
to become the leader
of the country being a
Native American himself.
There were so many fascinating
things about this character.
That's why we wanted
to tell a story,
and I think we found the right angle
with this historical anniversary.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
There was a question I had
because of all the events
that you could have chosen
to address [inaudible] Benito
Juarez, you chose this year,
this very particular
year for the docudrama.
>> Michela Giorelli: One other
reason why we chose this [inaudible]
because we thought it was a very --
he's not that well known like
[speaking foreign language]
and other things that just
came a couple of years before,
but it's a very decisive moment for
Mexican history and it's the end
of foreign intervention,
and it's a second --
it's like a second
struggle for independence,
almost a second defeat
of European power.
So it's significant, and I
think it's a beautiful story.
Republic [inaudible]
ran for four years
and so I think that's why
we chose this story of --
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: And
I want to congratulate you
for the lovely film that you made.
>> Michela Giorelli: Thank you.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: It
really is an important story
for the Hispanic public
to see and also
for the non-Hispanic public to see.
And you did a beautiful job.
>> Michela Giorelli:
Thank you very much.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: You even
gave Maximillian red hair.
>> Michela Giorelli:
That was difficult.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: I was so
shocked because I said to myself,
"They're not going to do that."
And there it was.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez: One of the
images that really captured my mind
as a librarian and as an
archivist want to be probably is
that the film opens up with
the archive and it closes
with the archive as well.
It's an important -- it plays an
important role throughout the movie.
So I would like you both to address
the archive as a narrative choice.
Why did you choose it to be so?
>> Michela Giorelli: Well for us
it's like a late motif of the film.
He sees himself as probably the
guardian of the nation as a way
of defending the nation, and
it's interesting obviously
for budget reasons we
couldn't visualize that,
but he left with 11
wagons of documents,
among them the declaration
of independence.
So we just thought it
was a beautiful way
of showing his patriotism
for Mexico.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: Well,
he should be the patron saint
of historians at least for
Mexicans because I can hardly think
of any dissertation or book
that could have been written
about Mexican history
without the archive.
And so we are incredibly indebted,
and the archive has moved in many,
many ways, many places
in Mexico City.
In fact, it's now housed in a
prison [speaking foreign language],
and it's sinking.
So there's going to have
to be another rescue.
I don't think we're going
to have to take the archives
to Chihuahua, at least I hope not.
I had to laugh because of course
Benito Juarez had to go to Chihuahua
and [speaking foreign language],
but the thing that's so funny
about it is to somebody from the
south and even from the center to go
to Chihuahua, I mean it's like --
>> Michela Giorelli: Desert.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: You can't
possibly imagine what that means,
and Chihuahua -- there's
a lot of desert there,
and it's not exactly considered --
I mean, when you say
[inaudible] Chihuahua,
I mean that gives you a sense
of how they feel about it,
and I love the part in the movie
where it shows U.S. on this side
and Mexico on the other side because
if he had set foot in the U.S.,
that would have been the end,
and he knew it very well.
And the movie conveys
that extraordinarily
that he couldn't get
any further north.
Now of course, he could have.
He could have gone to the west
and go into Baja, California.
But luckily he never had to do that.
But then how would he have
gotten -- I'm trying to think --
yeah, he would have had to
cross into the United States
in order to get the archives.
So luckily depression stirred up
trouble just at the right moment.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
How is the research process
for a documentary like this made?
>> Michela Giorelli: Yes.
Once we define the topic, we
hire a historical consultant
and in this case it was one
from the [inaudible] de Mexico.
And then --
>> Erica?
>> Michela Giorelli: Yeah, correct.
And then we did pre-interviews
with all the experts,
different specialties, some people
from the specialty
of the second empire.
We had there a military historian
[speaking foreign language].
So the different disciplines,
and we did a pre-interview
with all of them.
Once we had the pre-interview,
we write a script.
Then we do the official interview.
We recorded the interview with the
official already recorded interview.
We do the recreation
so we know exactly --
we have already chosen certain
moments we want to visualize,
and after that, we have again the
consultant reviewing everything is
fine and even doing the recreation
obviously for all the costumes,
the location, we have [inaudible]
involved in the project.
And then doing the postproduction
[inaudible] but it's process
that takes three to six
months to preproduction.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
Can you talk a little bit
about the effectiveness of docudrama
versus a more traditional
[crosstalk].
>> Michela Giorelli: I mean, I
love traditional documentary,
but I do see an advantage of
doing docudrama for the viewers.
It's a very engaging
way of telling a story
and also I think you can
humanize your character better.
In the case of Benito Juarez, many
people have seen a picture of him,
the photograph that we see here,
and there's a lot of stature,
but in this case we really wanted
to show him as the man of the family
and father and husband, and
you could only have done it
through dramatization, and I
think it's a very engaging way
of telling the story.
You take some freedom sometimes,
but that makes it more accessible
for our viewers, and we love
to make history accessible
and entertaining to all the views.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez: Barbara,
you have studied extensively the
relationship between the U.S.,
Mexico and we see that the U.S.
plays an important role even
in this -- during this intervention.
Could you elaborate
a little bit on it?
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: Well, I
would like to be able to say
that this was the last
intervention into Mexico.
But unfortunately, the United States
intervened twice in the 20th century
in Mexico, once to -- it's a
very confusing story that needs
to be really written
more extensively.
Once in [inaudible] where we were
there for probably almost a year
and the other was when [inaudible].
Yes, went into Columbus, New
Mexico and shot up the town
and killed some people and
so General Pershing went
with General Patton as his
[inaudible] into Mexico
which was a dress rehearsal
for World War I
for the U.S. intervention
into World War I.
On the other hand, to put in a
note, a positive note for a change,
about the United States and
Mexico, if it hadn't been
for Woodrow Wilson, Lord knows
what would have happened to Mexico
because Woodrow Wilson
refused to accept [inaudible]
who was a conservative as president
because he had gotten the presidency
through assassination
and thanks to his refusal
to recognize [inaudible] fell
and so Mexico became a
democratic state again,
and it's really quite remarkable.
Mexico is a very remarkable place.
For example, and this is something
that people don't make enough hay
about as far as I'm concerned,
in 1920 -- excuse me in 1829,
President [inaudible]
abolished slavery in Mexico.
Now you can see there's a big
difference between 1829 and 1865
when the United States did it.
Now for sure, there were a
lot fewer slaves in Mexico
but still it's the concept.
And if you think about
it hard, you'll realize
that it cost Mexico ultimately
55 percent of its territory
because the Texans were not going
to accept a nonslave republic
and so they won their
freedom in 1836.
Now, so the relationship
with the United States --
Porfirio Diaz famously
said poor Mexico,
so close to the United
States and so far from God.
And he had a point.
But on the other hand, Mexico had
as the United States
some superb leaders,
and in this particular case,
they were at the same time.
So you had Lincoln in the United
States and Juarez in Mexico and both
of them saved the nationality
of their respective republics,
and that was wonderful.
Now the fact that the United
States -- you see it in the film,
President Johnson says
America for the Americans.
What he meant was the south of the
United States for the United States.
But he did help in important
ways to save Mexican sovereignty,
and that was a very big
and wonderful thing.
So --
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez: Did Benito
Juarez ever visit the United States
as President of Mexico?
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: Well, I mean
he was there during his exile,
but he wasn't president at the time.
No, he did not, not as president,
the United States as
president, no, no.
And he never met with
President Lincoln,
although a lot of people
think he did.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez: I have two
more questions, but I want to see
if someone else has
questions for our specialists
and our executive producer
from the audience?
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: While
you're thinking of questions --
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
Don't be shy.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: Let me
tell you about Cinco de Mayo.
Many, many people --
>> Michela Giorelli: We did that --
by the way, we did a documentary,
a docudrama about Cindo de Mayo.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
Oh, you're producing it?
>> Barbara Tenenbaum:
I want to see it.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez: Excellent.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: Now many
of you or maybe none of you think
that Cinco de Mayo was
Mexican Independence Day.
It is not.
Cinco de Mayo represents a
battle that took place in 1862
between the Mexicans and the French.
And in this case, Ignacio Saragosa
[assumed spelling] who was head
of the Mexican Army and by the way
born in Texas, defeated the French.
It was one of those few cases
in which a Latin American power
defeated a European power.
And that is why it is celebrated in
California and in the United States.
Usually it's an opportunity
for us to have tacos and beer,
neither of which is a bad thing.
But it commemorates something
very, very serious and important.
In Mexico, of course,
they don't commemorate.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
Could you tell us something
about that documentary
that you're producing.
>> Michela Giorelli: Yeah, we did
it for the 150 year anniversary
of [inaudible], and we
used very similar --
we sort of took a couple of the
military both from the French side
and the Mexican side to humanize
the story, and then we --
it was a coproduction
with the state of Puebla.
So we had 200 army at our
disposal for the scenes.
It was a military -- it
was more of a battle.
So it was -- it was every
single different moment
of the battle were visualized.
So it was a different
document than this one.
It covered less time, but
it was very effective,
and it did very well
with our audience.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez: Excellent.
How does Discovery
choose their topics
for the documentaries and for the --
>> Michela Giorelli:
Documetnary or --
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
What is docudrama?
>> Michela Giorelli: Well,
generally we look at anniversaries
because it's always good to
be talking about something
that is relevant with the
present, and we try to find sort
of meaningful anniversary
for our Hispanic audience.
We have done two specials already
in [inaudible], one about the attack
of Columbus that you were
just mentioning before.
It was on last year.
We did something about a conspiracy
of the assassination
of Pancho Villa.
That was -- we did
[speaking foreign language].
We did something about independence
for the 200 year anniversary
of the independence of Mexico.
And we did -- that was
a little more difficult.
We did a biography on Porfirio Diaz.
It was difficult because he's a
very controversial figure in Mexico.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: Oh yes.
>> Michela Giorelli: And so we
had to really balance the story
and we started from the present
because there's a movement in Mexico
that would like his body
to be returned to Mexico
because it's buried in Paris.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: In
the [inaudible] cemetery.
>> Michela Giorelli: Yes.
So we look for fascinating
stories relevant,
and they have been
working very well,
especially with our Mexican
Hispanic audience here
in the U.S. I particularly
love to do them.
I learn a lot.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez: Is
there a docudrama that you would
like to produce that you're thinking
this is a moment we need to --
>> Michela Giorelli:
There is a lot of them.
I have a long list.
I would love to do the history
of Maxilimillian and Carlota
from their perspective about
this moment of history.
I think that's fascinating too.
Something about the Mexican American
wars will be interesting too.
We have never done
something specifically
about the revolution of Mexico.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: There's a
lot of stories for the revolution.
That's for sure.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
Very many stories to tell.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: Can I --
I'd like to make a note
here about two effects
of the French intervention
that were permanent.
One of them is that that term Latin
America comes from the Napoleon III.
It is an imperialist term.
So if you call yourself Latino and
Latina, you should think about it
because that -- Napoleon
said after all,
the western hemisphere
is mostly Catholic
and Romance language speaking so
therefore it's Latin American.
The other thing is
really quite funny.
When you think of Mexico, there are
several things that come to mind.
Tequila, for example, but also
what comes to mind are mariachi,
and the mariachi is -- there's a
lot of dispute but there is a school
of thought that says the
mariachi came from marriages
that were performed
during the empire,
and the French word
marriage became mariachi.
So and that has stuck.
So when you see a guy playing
an instrument whose got silver
up his leg, remember
that might have come
from a French wedding
somewhere in Mexico.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
Good story.
Maybe a story of the
mariachi [inaudible].
Before we go, Barbara, why
don't you tell our audience
of the marvelous -- you were the
Mexican specialist for many years
at the library and our
holdings have so many treasures.
Would you like to tell
them a little bit
of our collection in the library?
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: I mean,
our collection in the --
the wonderful thing about
the Library of Congress is
that it's a vehicle for surprise.
You say to yourself, oh they
can't have something on that.
And you look it up, and yes they do.
My favorite of those
is when I was --
we had to do something
about -- oh yeah.
We had to do something about
the [inaudible] and the Spanish
versus the indigenous and I
said, "They don't have anything
on Santiago de Compostela
the pilgrimage route
that people are still
taking to go to El Camino."
And low and behold in our rare
book division, there's a piece
of parchment that says you have --
because you have walked
the pilgrimage route,
it's a Santiago de Compostela,
you will receive the
following indulgences,
and it stays in the 13th century.
It's just amazing the
stuff that you could find
in the Library of Congress.
For Mexico, we have a book for
example that was a legal case
that the founder of La
Paz Baja, California.
His wife was trying
to get a noble title,
and there's a [inaudible]
piece that's in four colors
in gold leaf dating
from the 17th century.
The amount of materials that
we -- we have, for example,
a poem by Pabo [inaudible] that was
written on the remnants of the linen
from shirts during the Spanish Civil
War because they didn't have paper
so they had to use this linen.
It's just absolutely amazing
what the Library of Congress has.
We have a gift in the reading room.
Come see the Hispanic Reading Room.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
We have a picture
of Benito Juarez in
our reading room.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: We have
a picture of Benito Juarez
that was given to us by
President [inaudible] in the 70's.
We have the only murals in the
Library of Congress that were done
by a Brazilian artist, [inaudible].
That, of course, I don't
say this in front of her,
but that's because Nelson
Rockefeller was paying,
and he wasn't going
to let Diego Rivera,
God forbid, paint the murals.
And of course if Diego Rivera
had painted the murals,
we would have lines around
the block waiting to see.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez: Come on.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: We would.
We would.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
Having [inaudible] murals is
absolutely fantastic, and Michela,
you should come and
see them definitely.
>> Michela Giorelli: I will.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez: and
the portrait by Benito Juarez.
It's wonderful because
people walk in --
>> Michela Giorelli: I
have a question for you.
Do you know if it's true
that Bernito Mussolini was
named after Benito Juarez?
Have you ever heard this story?
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: No.
I don't think that's true.
>> Michela Giorelli: His
parents were socialists and --
I don't know, it's just I heard
this story, and I wondered if --
>> Barbara Tenebaum: I'm going
to ask the Italian specialist.
>> Michela Giorelli:
Okay, thank you.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez: Is it
something you've heard then that --
>> Barbara Tenenbaum:
I've never heard it.
>> Michela Giorelli: I heard these
rumors, and I was just curious.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: I doubt it.
But I will check on it for you.
>> Michela Giorelli: Thank you.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
Interesting.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum:
You have to give me --
did you give me your card?
>> Michela Giorelli: I will.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez: Do
we have any questions from --
oh, there's one, one
all the way to the back.
There's a microphone.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: I can't see.
>> Do you have any comment about
Hollywood's version of Juarez,
the film Juarez that was made
in 1930 starring Paul Mooney?
And how inaccurate
or accurate was that?
I know it wasn't based on
primary sources and everything,
but the film Juarez
starring Paul Mooney.
>> Michela Giorelli:
I haven't seen it.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum:
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
I haven't seen it.
>> Michela Giorelli: I
heard, but I know the --
we didn't see it for this.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: No.
None of us have seen it.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez: Sorry.
Anyone else?
Catalina?
>> I'm curious about
where the scenes --
the docudrama scenes are filmed.
Did you guys go to Mexico
to the different places
or did you have a set here?
>> Michela Giorelli: Yeah,
I mean, we did most of them
in the area close to the effect,
some of the colonial haciendas
and for the desert sequence,
we went to which is not too far
from Mexico City also,
Hidalgo and there is a couple
of scene in the area of Pueblo.
So [inaudible] is one, but
they were just around the --
not to far from the effect.
Yes.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
Don't be shy.
>> Thank you for your comments.
Recognizing the Hispanic heritage
is not only Mexican heritage,
is discovery planning other
Latin American countries films
and documentaries and doc dramas?
>> Michela Giorelli:
We would love to.
We did a few.
We did [inaudible], the
wife of [inaudible].
We -- yeah we would love
to explore more characters.
We will eventually I think.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
There's audience for --
>> Michela Giorelli: Yes, yes.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: Absolutely.
>> Michela Giorelli: For sure.
And there are countless stories
and countless characters.
>> Barbara Tenenbaum: Definitely.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
Well, I think this is it.
Thank you so much, Michela, for the
wonderful film and for allowing us
to show it here at the
Library of Congress.
I'm sure we'll have people
come and ask questions.
>> Michela Giorelli: We actually
would like to make a donation
to the Library -- the
original script.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
Oh wonderful.
Fantastic.
>> Michela Giorelli:
Of the docudrama.
>> Talia Guzman Gonzalez:
That's great.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.